We've been using the word set to describe
these different groups of numbers and
that's exactly what a set is, a collection
of numbers. So, the natural numbers is the
set 1,2,3 and so forth. And the whole
numbers is the set 0, 1, 2, 3 and so
forth. And we might represent the set of
integers like this with ellipses on both
ends to represent going on to infinity. We
usually denote sets with these curly
braces around the numbers and commas
between the numbers we give certain sets.
Like the ones we've talked about special
names. But really a set can be made up of
any numbers that we put together for
whatever reason. So for example, this set
-4, 7, 19 is a set. And so is -38, 56,
100.5. As is 9. Now, since all of the
numbers in the set of natural numbers are
also in the set of whole numbers, we call
the natural numbers a subset of the whole
numbers. A subset of a set, is another set
of numbers that are all contained in the
original set. So its a little bit of
practice to make sure you understand what
sets and subsets are. Here's a random set
of numbers, -4 -3, 0, 0.6, 1, 5, and 8. Which
of the choices below are subsets of the
set? You may pick more than one answer.